hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to Blair which now
we've got something in the woods that's
lurking for us hey buddy
bullet bullet where ya boy where ya can
you come here can you seek something
Zeke go find where we need to go go oh
that's okay you're still alright sickles
me I'm gonna go the way that this symbol
was pointing us towards also I turned
the light back on it it's a little bit
uh moodier now that the Sun has gone
down just me the night sky and the empty
woods waiting for me the things lurking
in the darkness hiding around every
corner it's nice I I think it's
fascinating because what this game does
really well is it replicates the kind of
jarring disconnected feeling of the
found-footage thing where the world is
changing and morphing before my very
eyes and it's all just a series of woods
that continue on and on and you find
yourself looping back and forth over
again and you just have no idea where
everything
I'm sorry I was looking straight out
there and that changed I'm sorry was
that just the game loading in or was
that actually supposed to be like that I
don't know why excuse M well that was so
sudden I think it must have just been
the game loading right or was that
intentional what do you got what do you
got boy well what do you got I'm sorry
I'm really old come here
holy come here I'm gonna pitch it but
you better better get off the goddamn
bear trap you better go hey aren't you a
handsome boy how'd you hurt your boy
let's play right here this bear trap
let's do it alright I don't think it's
armed well of course it's armed the jaws
are open everything's good what you
looking at buddy
okay good Lisa dude let's just mosey on
let's mosey on if he had actually been
hit by that thing I never would have
been able to forget myself my face oh
hey come on now you can't do that to me
you can't do that how did we loop back I
don't know about that one okay I also
forgot that we have another movie so we
should watch that okay we already
watched the am aside and missus emesis
aside emic aside what about the next
tape there's another tape right didn't I
get a tape I got a tape the burial here
we go
it's him uh it's him buried something
nearby let's find it buddy
uh-huh
I see so we're looking for some pretty
pretty flowers is what we're looking for
oh I'm gonna find some pretty pretty
flowers oh where oh where could some
pretty pretty flowers be up here maybe
like someone's trying to hide something
from me which they won't be able to
because I'm too smart ooh hello again
things being little weird no no that's
impossible
yeah well let's move on yeah yeah let's
move on I don't know why the woods keep
changing like that huh oh wait here we
go wait wait yes yeah oh hello
call oral Carl okay I don't know why all
these really weird photographs looks
ancient come on boy let's leave it alone
yeah you can tell by the white paint
circling it it's ancient as hell okay so
I need to look at the thing and I need
to rewind
when this wasn't there flippity food
flippity doo-dah easy-peasy
hey bar I get your digging paws over
here and let's dig us up with two brains
hey boy what's what's that yeah yeah
keep going yeah oh you're so good at
digging buddy you're so good Oh howdy
East Creek timber company why would you
bury why I seen his low before the
landings going
it's worth a shot maybe we'll finally
get some answers what do you mean what
do you mean that's where landing was
going how do you know that's where
landing was going hey Marlon come sniff
this out
boom smooth news it's important long
with really scooped it up there okay oh
he's on the trail
alright bullet let's go wherever we're
going what the longest Ike I I've been
getting achievements left and right and
I don't know why but I love ya what's up
what's up bud yeah come on Bullock go go
go come on we got something to find I'm
not sure why exactly what we're gonna
find oh oh yeah this ilizarov five why
I'm sorry
hello what who is this okay oh oh
yep another one yeah that's good yeah
that's good oh yeah this seems normal
yeah there's definitely some PTSD
something or other going on and I don't
know why bullet is along for the ride
and I don't know how bullet is along for
the ride but that doesn't matter this is
not real I think that maybe they're a
little more real than youth on coal oh
boy oh this weird okay
we're hey but leaves though forget to
jump around and roll around and leaves
this in that Gray's Ron often owes it I
need my flashlight what is it boy
shoo shoo shoo shoo shoo it's okay buddy
okay it's okay buddy it's okay oh yeah
oh my god bolon get back here won't stay
away from the leaves bullet okay yeah
that's weird
okay yeah that's normal that's that's
all normal okay I'm going for it but but
Oh bollocks siglos okay you stay close
yes stay close buddy
here we go here we go
usually I like leaves they're fun okay
good good boy bullet good boy good boy
who's a good boy you're a good boy good
boy you're a good boy bullet who use a
good boy use a good boy bullet use a
good boy okay I think we lost them
oh no we didn't okay I think we're doing
hi hi hi hey oh okay okay come on bullet
would come on boy come on boy come on
boy come on
okay bullet bullet bullet bullet good
boy
okay this gonna be a bit of a longer run
bullet oh oh I don't know what you are
but you don't look fun that's for sure
okay we go
oh well oh yeah I didn't know that it
was right on top of me that's weird
okay I'm gonna run around you okay good
bye bullet good boy okay good boy I Oh
wowie wow I'm sorry I wouldn't jump run
buddy hey buddy what's going on oh oh
gosh you fast oh I hate that it's so
fast
[Music]
bowling is so good you're such a good
boy it's such a good boy who's such a
good boy you said you're good boy I get
so many treats you go get so many good
boy treats you're gonna get so many good
boy treats oh you're such a good boy
such a good boy
maybe later baby now you're such a good
boy such a good boy such a girl here we
go
okay Oh interesting cow
hey is it cuz I was standing still oh
alright we're going for we're just gonna
go for it buddy come on out
right oh oh oh my god oh okay we just
fully in it then
okay we're fully in and out we're just
here
oh hi okay never mind my friend
pull it where's bullet okay
[Music]
oh-oh-oh
okay um hey bullet they are bull you're
such a good boy such a good boy
[Laughter]
all this would never hold see - let go -
but no I'm good I'm good right here I'm
right here doing good this hog feels
very supple go hug cheek after this here
we go that's good that's good boy that's
a good boy that's a good boy you get a
good boy treat if ever there was a time
to give a good boy a good boy treat now
is the time I'm gonna give you a good
boy treat I'm okay yeah okay hey good
boy good boy
what's a treat come here boy come here
boy you get a treat you get a drink oh
boy you can treat you did so good boy
enjoy
there you go that's a good boy this is
the grade skip greatest game ever in
history forever
such a good boy he's so good oh you're
such a good boy who's such a good boss
get close to me it's too close to me
okay here we go back and do it again
this is so so surreal so there's some
kind of PTSD thing along with the curse
of whatever's going wrong with this
forest which means that combined it's
the witch I think the Witch of the woods
trying to like affect my mind that
looked like a person reaching out I
don't know if that was intentional or
not okay hey I see signs of what was
former civilization I'm sure that that's
going to go good for me okay here we go
thunk what's up you okay good dog good
dog
oh good dog I don't know what was going
on but did you see something you shoot
up a good boy what do you got nothing
there huh
Oh what about here Oh premise law
presume is a lie alright bud
he'll stay closed I don't think we're
out of the woods yet oh sorry it was a
bad joke I know
hey that's I don't know I think we're
good there I think we can go into that I
don't know what those things are but I
don't like him
well it's has mania devil things what
you got what you got buddy what you got
all right okay we'll go this way we'll
go this way it's good yeah good idea
good idea okay good boy good boy sawmill
camp eh
well I don't know which one I want to go
to first oh there's so many good choices
here okay well I'm not going that way so
I guess I'm going to camp
hey camp a baby is that a railroad track
you mean the thing that Amit's think
that I'm running on right now what do
you got buddy
ooh what do you got what do you got what
do you see something
oh I'm petting you meant to get you to
seek something Wow whatever good boy
pets for good boys oh oh good boy who's
a good boy who's a good boy very good
now see if you can find Oh Oh what you
got okay all right good job good job
can you just stick it all right let's go
I gotta follow this to wherever it's
going
oh do I still search maybe I could call
Jess hey uh one second one second bullet
hey Jess
[Music]
you know just checking in
checking out
how are you oh hey let's see you run
around at dark muddy forest for a while
and it doesn't really help with your
romancing skills Jessie there's
something really messed up going on in
these woods sorry you know I can't
explain it now I wouldn't even know
where to start just
he's not yet sorry just uh I gotta go
okay yeah sure yeah okay yeah okay okay
yeah sure yeah okay just some weird how
did they get here dog tags from my
former squad mates yes normal it's
normal
hey some weirds going on here just I
don't know oh I love you too by the way
whose cars dude voicemail you have one
new voicemail that's good I was hoping
for that and boy I get a voicemail well
that was a fun voicemail glad I listened
to that one hey bullet where are we
going buddy hey everything is good in
this neighborhood oh I love a bridge I
love a haunted bridge I love it I love
it okay hey well you're broken okay all
right I love a good haunted bridge and I
love the possibility of me getting run
over in the middle of it with a train
that beautiful okay yeah it's normal
normal rail cart normal very normal very
normal
okay yeah yeah yeah yeah I just hopped
in here
was there anything else before I come on
boy jump on oh good boy is it good boy
boy you're doing are a bullet you doing
ok all right well here we go
Railway diagram directional ever power
switch brake lever brake lever do they
know who I am
do they even understand what this face
represents I don't need no brakes brakes
chums
chump chump stuff let's go baby all
speed all ahead I can't see anything I
oh now we're on all speed all ahead full
backup
forward maybe I should have wrote the
time
alright Paris Monsieur very clever ah is
the brake on of the brake is engaged
there we are all ahead full baby alright
whatever demon gets in my way they're
about to get a face full of train how
you doing buddy yeah buddy good bar good
I'm good I'm good dad drawer
still [ __ ] yeah oh come on still with
me boy mr. Libi boy maybe I should have
watched where I was going boy
you alright buddy
guard alright good boy okay I think
we're here I guess oh there's a log as
it turns out let me put the brakes on
before I remove the loggers Kerpelman
let's go boy oh that's just get back in
there looks like a logger to push aside
well not for me
operation out here stop getting a permit
in the 60s
yeah well it hasn't stepped anything
here before it's so what if it's ancient
doesn't matter to me ancient technology
doesn't even remotely phase me oh hey
what's up bud about this rewinds time
here we go
[Music]
just that easy huh
and then you get your knife and you
start your murdering your stab and your
stab well thanks bud okay cool thanks
thanks bud hey bud hey thanks and thanks
bud hey thanks thank you
okay what do we got here all right
whistle safety valve pressure I love a
good whistle steam-powered donkey engine
Oh steam donkey all the way up the
middle it looks promising
spare parts left all right let's see
okay dream guy name is PJ we just got a
new delivery come to the maintenance
shed to pick up the parks you wanted
Robert to Gendry that's what you keep
Petrie for your parents named you such
stupid name I'm sorry for anybody out
there named Guidry I apologize
okay what are we missing now but the
handles missing panels missing on the
valve okay so I got go I gotta go find
myself a donkey all right come on boy we
gotta go find in terms of what's that I
think that's where a donkey is it's real
dark it's like really dark money should
be safer this way okay buddy let's hope
it's still standing
kachunk oh I smell nothing first buddy
where's the buddy buddy where'd that
buddy where's that good oh there yeah I
see you yeah that's right buddy yeah I
mean bullet we got this oh we've got
this oh yeah oh you think you can get
away from me and bullet you cannot oh I
hate your speed those good boy hates
what you a handsome boy yeah dog to dog
legs are a little messed up there it's
too close to me and nothing bad is gonna
happen to you not on my watch oh not on
my watch not on my watch oh good I'm so
sorry
all right well that's a thing that's
there for some reason I keep expecting
to find like herbs or something because
of this kind of does have a little bit
of a resident evil vibe to it but you
know I gotta throw that all right what
do we got here pressure gauge to grind
and belt time by Robert please make an
order for more Valve's can't be took the
last one for their steamed donkey and
now we're out of spares all right so I
gotta go to wherever can't be is it's
like we won't be getting in through here
well looks like I gots to go around what
a load of malarkey you know
and I smash my way through here oh oh
let go get it
apparently oh let go get it oh you such
a good boy who's a good boy who's a good
boy yeah are you so good I'll use a good
boy Oh you's a good boy you's a good boy
you's a good boy use your good boy I
love you this when it's clean use good
boy okay good boy you did so good you
did so good now we need to go over to
camp be for the Val Val they think we
gotta go there for the valve so why why
making noises like that right okay can't
be I think I just gotta follow the
tracks
whatever you say that's a nice tree
anybody seen the donkey anybody else bye
I spy with my eye a donkey
well here we go I don't know why I'm
doing this great that definitely did
something not I represent sure what but
it did something oh so now I won't crash
and die in camp B well let me just
cranky ank this I'm sure nothing bad
will happen thank you oh sure some mad
Oh me good thing me and bullet are such
hardcore badass yeah yeah you try you
try you try you won't you won't you
won't you won't you only won't you won't
you won't
oh don't want that won't you won't oh
bullet you didn't warn me okay so I do
need to follow the sounds I'm hearing
that's right that's right that's right
back off back off back off back off oh
yeah I heard that
yeah good boy good boy good boy good boy
good boy good boy
okay heard strange noise from behind me
but imma assume it's nothing you let me
know if there's demons standing directly
behind me you'll let me know right you
let me know if there was a demon down
the drain oh I can turn around it's
right there oh just kidding there's
something behind you not me okay anyway
let's go find ourselves a donkey Wow I
apologize for the amount of sass I've
been giving you game I apologize to take
it I can't take it out with the power on
[Laughter]
I didn't expect that
am I going the right way I think I'm
going back now I'm going the right way
okay I can't I can't take it up with the
power up guys as I've discovered it did
turn the power off okay it's not even
letting me it was like you stupid idiot
you don't even deserve to be able to
take the fuse out I hope I haven't
broken the game really hope sincerely
hope background summary and reasons for
referral patient brought in by parents
due to extreme panic attacks insomnia
and sleepwalking after a traumatic
experience I advised three therapeutic
sessions per week during a preliminary
interview I was able to determine the
following the patient actively avoids
recalling the event he experiences
visited nightmares since the event
possibly coping mechanism he exhibits an
emotional numbness irrational aggression
and dissociation of through the event
overall he is very nervous
possibly undiagnosed anxiety and
neurosis okay great anybody seen a
donkey anybody spy an eye on a donkey
alright man they were not good about
getting logs Oh willow yes it's not good
yes it's it's not good oh not what you'd
call good not sure where I'm going can't
even smell a donkey down this way
usually these snore furs can smell a
donkey from a mile away I can't smell a
ding-dong damn donkey think wait there's
something up there was that I can't get
over there can I get up there apparently
not
logs we just been penetrable but I see
you so there's got to be a way to get up
over there Oh aha well that would have
been easy to miss okay donkey donkey
this one is barely holding up
see if there's anything was salvaged you
mean it's not holding up at all because
it's kind of fallen over and on the
ground you should do it yeah that looks
good to me I like to look at that one
okay now what's in here explosive barrel
that I can blow myself up with great
good eye that's clipping when I took the
camera from that old fool it was full of
senseless chatter but I saw it I saw the
things that can really do through it I
can look into the darkness and see the
creatures that lurk where without being
seen through it I can see the things
that escape my eyes and through it I can
get his back into things I've done it
won't let me forget okay it's a little
weird oh hey if only you'd what I don't
think there's anything you could have
done man roars hell and all that you're
a kitty boy you're good boy okay let's
just mosey on back then like nothing was
ever the problem after all come on buddy
I can do that too come on bullet bullet
bullet bullet bullet bullet there you go
go boy you made a pair of Angele good
boy good boy gonna give you good boy
pens he's a good boy who's a good boy
you good boy a good boy I'm sorry but
I'm gonna keep doing this
who's your good boy who's your good boy
I've gotta find our way back to wherever
the hell we were hoping to go oh did I
remember there being glow ominously
glowing from over there because I don't
think I recall that that's probably
where I'm gonna end up going and what I
probably did for the switch track was
prevent me from going down this plane
doom
I thought I heard something yeah I think
I'm gonna go that way eventually all
right so close to me but you know I
guess I could have gone around what if I
had just backed up and gone the other
way wait a minute wait wait a minute
hang on before I do this ham before I
clear this which I'm obviously going to
do okay good good good let's do it to
break off let's back her up and then
what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna switch he
switch that and I'm gonna take this down
yonder way to see where I'm going now
I'm willing to bet that it's probably
just uh uh uh wait wait wait wait wait
brakes there we go probably just
something to help me get down there so I
didn't have to run the whole way but I
didn't think about that but I do want to
find out where this goes because why
would it be there right
full speed ahead all right let's see
where she goes I don't know where she's
gonna go oh my god god damn it scared
the poopoo pee out of me all right now
where the hell is this going this isn't
the same bridge that I crossed before I
don't think anyway cuz why would it have
been just a big loop unless it is just a
big loop in which case I don't know why
I'm going on a big loop wait a minute
wait wait wait wait man that doesn't
make knows to hang on hang on oh just it
breaks that's just a little bit
suspicious it's just you know you get a
little suspicious and I
I don't know about that I don't know
about that guys I think the baby there's
something a little bit suspicions about
what's going on there
all right anyway breaks leave this in
good ol neutral let's go boys
let's go bowling let's change this back
I guess - I'm a little [ __ ] space ready
double steno about that so I'm speed
Filippo furred oh you're so goddamn cute
this show god damn dude oh I hope I do
the Wow I'm gonna do that to Chico later
couch oh good join Keith okay now I
don't know if I have a lighter I don't
have a lighter
[Music]
I don't have a lighter anybody got a
light man about it
anybody got a light is Arcadius la Katie
some of these names are cool
honey but got light anybody anybody got
a light well guess I'm just stuck until
I find a light so I'm gonna end this one
here because I don't know where a light
be Oh dog tag
[Music]
[ __ ] fault hey how about that doesn't
seem like it might be but yeah what do I
know I wasn't there maybe is your fault
probably not but I don't know okay so I
don't have a lighter do I know I don't
have a lighter
okay so I'm gonna end this one here
because I don't know where the lighter
is so I have to go find it it's probably
back in one of the other locations and I
just missed over it I'm just gonna have
bullit go looking for it for me but
thank you everybody so much for watching
I really like this it's super weird and
it's super cool and sometimes it does
get me it's overall more of a game about
the environment the ambiance than pure
just like boosts cares which is cool I
like it cuz I'm intrigued by the story I
don't know where it's gonna go next and
I love this surreal bizarre nature of
these woods it's super cool so thank you
everybody so much for watching let me
know what you think in the comments
below and as always I will see you in
the next video bye bye
[Music]